so much of what Megan is and how she is
so similar to my mom for years people
have been drawing parallels between the
late Princess Diana and her
daughter-in-law Meghan Markle and now
Prince Harry he says he agrees with them
on Thursday Netflix dropped the first
three episodes of Harry and Megan's
self-titled docu-series and the Duke of
Sussex says his wife reminds him of his
mom in tons of ways
she has the same compassion she has the
same empathy she has the same confidence
she has this warmth about her megave a
sweet and subtle nod to princess die
earlier this week at the 2022 Ripple of
Hope Gala in NYC rocking a ring that
once belonged to the people's princess
it's the same gem Megan sported during
her wedding reception back in 2018. that
aquamarine Cartier ring from Diana's
collection which had been left for Harry
he waited until their wedding night to
give it to her a really beautiful and
lovely tribute to Diana and Diana was
top of Mind during this sweet and rare
moment with Megan and Harry's son Archie
that's your Grandma Diana of course the
couple decided to step back from their
Royal duties in 2020 and began a new
life in California where they are
raising their two children Archie and
lillibet there is no question of a doubt
that Meghan markle's life has changed
she'd be naive to have got into this
relationship without realizing that
getting involved with Prince Harry was
going to attract a global interest here
he also opens up about the pressure that
members of the royal family feel when
choosing their partner I think for so
many people in the family especially
obviously the men there can be a
Temptation or an urge to marry someone
[Music]
who
would fit in the mold as opposed to
somebody who you perhaps are destined to
to be with the difference between making
decisions with your head
or your heart but Harry says his mom
made most if not all of her decisions
with her heart a trait he says he
inherited and I out my mother's son so
what does Harry's fam think of the new
Netflix project well the docu-series
kicks off with the disclaimer that reads
quote members of the royal family
declined to comment on the content
within the series but now a source tells
E.T the royal family is not aware of any
such approach for comment meanwhile a
Netflix Source tells ET that
Communications offices for King Charles
and Prince William were contacted in
advance and given the right to reply to
the claims in the series
et's asked the streamer for proof my
understanding is that the palace receive
an email from a third party on behalf of
Netflix asking for comment the palace
then tried to verify the authenticity of
this email by contacting Netflix and
archwell and there is we understand no
response I'm told by a senior Palisade
it's a case of keep calm and carry on
and let's not get too distracted by this
[Music]